we nearly got a quencing Tarantino Star
Trek movie what the hell do that look
like when I lay my vengance upon welcome
to serek your SciFi TV I'm Movie Channel
there have been plans since 2016 for a
another Star Trek movie before Star Trek
Beyond was released in fact it was
announced that bad robot and Sky Dan
were going to continue in the
collaboration and bring Star Trek back
once more now Star Trek Beyond didn't do
great at the box office it's to say and
those plans stuttered but what would we
have got and why didn't it happen well
recently in the interview Mark L Smith
the guy that wrote the script for Star
Trek 4 has been talking about what he
hoped he was going to see and why it
didn't happen or at least one of the
main reasons why Quenton Tarantino was
going to direct this and he was going to
quent and Tarantino it according to Mark
L Smith Quenton Tarantino did agree to
come on as the Director but his only
provisor was that it would have to be an
R8 or for the English an 18 Markel Smith
talks about how this project would have
been a hard R rating as well he talked
about Pulp Fiction style violence and he
said that it would have been an absolute
GameChanger for the Star Trek franchise
he very modestly says not because of his
writing but because of what quent and
Tarantino was planning to do with it now
Quenton Tarantino is famous for his
movies like Pulp Fiction but for me I
remember the CSI episodes he directed
and what he brought to that those were
insanely good episodes of Television
some of the best CSI episodes ever made
and actually to be fair some of the best
television ever made markl Smith talks
about how tarantina would have brought
similar energy to the Star Trek
franchise and it would have been a
GameChanger he talks about how Tarantino
would have completely changed Star Trek
forever he actually referenced um Thor
Ragnarok as an example how when taoti
came in and put a bit of taer on the
Marvel Universe it completely changed
the future it was the standout Marvel
movie and for me probably the best
Marvel movie they ever did it's probably
my favorite Star Trek You could argue is
stagnating a little bit at the moment
the movies 100% stagnated they redid the
wrath of K in a way don't know what they
were quite doing with Star Trek Beyond
but you know it was an okay film
but and for me the movie franchises
desperately needed shaking up we needed
tarano for this and if we'd have got it
I think it would have completely
reinvigorated the Star Trek franchise I
think a lot of Star Trek fans are a
little bit irritated by the current
curtzman Star Trek and having JJ Abrams
anywhere bloody near it is a little bit
of a concern but having Sky Dan and Bad
Robot involved in this when Tarantino
would be in charge now I don't think
that would have been a problem at all it
would have been a Fallout balls out Star
Trek movie so why didn't it happen well
Mark actually talked in this collider
interview about how Tarantino couldn't
quite get his head around the idea that
a Star Trek film could be his last movie
that he doesn't expect to do more than a
couple of projects now and he's
basically already thinking about his
retirement and he couldn't get over this
hump in the road of what if that's my
last film he never could quite get over
that and that's one of the main reasons
why the project kind of fizzled out now
I think we can argue that maybe the
whole thing with the massive flop of
Star Trek Beyond was also a problem but
to be honest if quent and tarantine had
put his name on a new project and that
had actually got the executives excited
enough I think they'd have gone for it
now when I first heard that Quenton
Tarantino was thinking about doing a
Star Trek movie I couldn't get my head
around that at all I was thinking about
Samuel L Jackson in a Star Trek uniform
and yeah no it didn't work for me but in
hindsight looking back on it I can't
help but think how desperately the
franchise needs this it needs that kick
up the ass it needs completely fresh
thinking and I think markl Smith when he
mentions Ragnarok has banged that nail
Square on the head because actually that
is what we need we need that shock we
need to go to a Star Trek movie and come
out afterwards going well that's not
what we used to that was completely
mental we need to have some Tarantino
moments that we will then remember
because that is one of the problems with
Star Trek and I would argue also with
Star Wars that there are no iconic
moments anymore Star Trek Into Darkness
was supposed to bring us some of those
iconic moments the whole reason why they
hired Benedict Cumberbatch was because
they wanted a heavyweight actor to
deliver those lines like
con and it didn't work I would actually
argue that not only there no iconic
moments in new track and I'm going to
include the TV series there as well they
even struggle with having just memorable
moments if you actually think about the
original movies there are moments like
come and the needs of the many outweigh
the needs of the few there were these
moments in all of those Star Trek movies
like when they release the whales out
into the river etc etc that were
properly iconic that even people that
don't necessarily love sci-fi remember
and I think Quenton Tarantino would have
brought us some of those icon I moments
so I cannot help but look back on this
now with a little bit of
sadness we really really needed a
Quenton Tarantino movie we really really
needed somebody brave enough to kick in
the doors at Bad Robot and go this is
the film that we need we don't need all
your lens flares we don't need this
storyline what we need is something that
fans are going to go nuts over sci-fi
fans quite like a bit of violence we
like those moments that shock us
sometimes we like to have a movie that
forces us to think we want something in
Star Trek at the moment that's going to
shock us we need it and if Quenton
Tarantino isn't going to do it who
will so this is unfortunately a sad
video it's a video about a possibility
that was missed out on but if Paramount
have got any sense of at all they will
get rid of curtzman who has not been
directing this ship the way we want it
to go and they will get in some new
Brave creators fans of Star Trek fans of
sci-fi fans that are willing to kick
those doors in and do something that
will shock us because the Star Trek
franchise for me desperately needs it
but guys what do you think get to the
comments does Star Trek feel like it
need to kick up the ass and I'm going to
throw Star Wars into this as well are
these the two real juggernauts of sci-fi
Flander in a bit at the moment they seem
to be too scared to rock the boat
there's a lot of boat metaphors in this
episode they seem to be too scared to
upset people even though they are quite
willing to do musicals that upset the
crap out of me so what do they need do
they need a kick up the ass do they need
something that is completely different
get into the comments and tell me me
what you think if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification it really helps us out
and you'll never miss any of our new
videos also you can go to patreon.com
citre where most of our new videos
Premiere first so you'll get to see them
before everyone else also there crack.
co.uk which is our dedicated website
where we do articles based on most of
our videos go check that out too as
always please stay safe and I'll see you
next
time
[Music]